okay so you're sitting at your desk one
morning watching anime or some [ __ ] like
the filthy dirty disgusting weave that
you are when suddenly you get this
epiphany from Jesus or Buddha or whoever
you're worshipping on that day and they
tell you my child it is time for you to
make your own anime and change the world
and you're like yes I always knew was my
destiny to one day make my own anime
like the filthy dirty disgusting weave
that I am but upon reflecting on it a
little further you realize you know
nothing about anime production so you
don't even know where to start well
today you're in luck as here you can
learn the basics of what it takes to
make your favorite trash show 41
shirobako without watching Shara bark oh
well the first obvious step is to be
Japanese cuz there's not an anime if
you're white all right you're done mate
get over it alright so you've hit the
jackpot and you have some kind of
Japanese heritage in you congratulations
you can now start pre-production now
assuming you don't have a spare a few
million dollars just lying around the
house and uncle Derek isn't gonna lend
you the odd 100 to 300 K to find your
new business venture in Asian cartoon
lands cuz that's like at least 10,000
trips to Nando's and who would want to
sacrifice a spicy succulent taste of
Nando's chicken for this crap no you'll
need to suck some major dick to be part
of a committee consisting of the
production company or anomie studios
where you can pitch your idea for the
next profitable anime yep did you catch
the most important word in that last
sentence that's right Dave oh sorry
profitable yes first and foremost the
only thing these guys care about is how
much moolah is likely to make since
they'll be the ones fronting the cash
for it look I know you have that great
new original idea that would make likes
of Madoka one punch man and Stein's get
[ __ ] itself in comparison but unless
your name is mr. miyazaki shinb oh my
she Hosoda Shinkai or bushy wantanabe
son or a few other select people no
one's gonna trust your idea to make a
dime right so the anime original 'very
is out the question so let's stick with
the language that everyone here is
guaranteed to understand manga Android
mobiles
these have a pre-existing fan base they
can sell too and the story is already
there
oh sorry though nobody really thinks
adapting that original multi-layered
deconstruction of mature anime with
mature characters is a great idea though
we got a thing simpler ya take words you
think are important like character
development depth story structure and
shut them out the window now is the main
character generically bland who's
overpowered in some way so the audience
can self insert themselves into great
we're onto something does it have enough
tits in it
are there big enough variety of tips is
every tip attracted to the main
character in some way I don't even care
one of them is a sister she doesn't even
have to be related in any way make her
an adopted second cousin to his
estranged are to some [ __ ] but most
importantly is there enough [ __ ] tits
in it no congratulations now go make the
next Kuroko no yaoi on ice it's
important you pick source material that
is likely to generate sales or has an
opportunity to make extra income through
merchandising I mean [ __ ] those hundreds
of naked REM docume curries aren't gonna
sell themselves um did I punch in high
school oh yeah pick something in high
school
alternatively if none of this sounds
appealing and you do have a [ __ ] ton of
cash lying around you can always go to
crunchyroll son to introduce you to some
anime studio and hope they like your
pitch hey I've got this great idea about
making this anime music video kind of
thing that looks really cool and has
this touching story about fatherly love
and like moving forward from painful
memories yeah sorry man we're not really
interested but he has ago trapped in a
virtual reality oh my god let me suck
your dick alright so they all set on
some kind of light novel adaptation of a
magic harem high-school show complete
with a cinder a heroine whose only
redeeming qualities that she can suck a
golf ball through a garden hose not
exactly what you're hoping for but [ __ ]
it it's been approved now some for you
to pick you're a team of Staff members
who will try the hardest to make this
not suck some important roles note at
this stage is the director script
supervisor and character designer
directors will oversee the entire
project and will have the final say in
any decision made about the anime the
script supervisor helps plan out the
series composition which is a fancy way
of saying they plan out the basics of
what happens in each episode of the
anime or in other words hey let's get
ready to make everyone lose their
[ __ ] heads over episode three am i
right lads and lastly the character
designers job is to obviously design the
characters dick adds once the basics of
the story and designs are mapped out
it's time to write the show sometimes
one person hammers it and sometimes a
team of writers working with the script
supervisor but yes all of this does mean
that someone somewhere on paper had to
write out such masterpieces and then the
girl confidently targeted her small
titted opponent with her
only to be surprised that her boobs are
transformed into a big bouncy but as all
that remained of her was but an after
image of where her tits once stood yeah
man I think we're definitely unaware of
this time next up we get to as a
storyboarding this is normally done by
the director locked in a cage being
forced to draw storyboards until we
either finishes or starves to death of
course this is just a scene from Shara
Barco an actual industry standard
methods for getting a director to finish
that storyboards are far more humane
probably the storyboards break down the
anime episodes into different cuts now
exactly what a car tears is a bit
different from live-action see a cartoon
live-action films when you simply cut
from one shot to another like this hello
but an anime icon refers to a single
shot of the imaginary camera since every
new shot requires new background to be
painted along with the new animation
movement alright that's a pretty good
take we can cut now clarifies it down
whole time wise thing walk from the
storyboards the layout of each cut can
be created a layout in simple terms is a
more detailed blueprint than the
storyboards given the positioning of the
cell and the background art though we
needed for each cut once that's done we
can move to the biggest part of anime
the anime ting based on the storyboard
key animators are given a certain number
of cuts where they have to draw the
essential frames and distinct position
that goes into animating a certain scene
essentially they're in charge of the
basic structure of animation and around
20 key animators given different parts
can be working on a single episode of
anime at a time key animators are kind
of like the lead guitarists of the
animation world as although the key
animators have to follow the movement
structure presented in the storyboard
they are given creative freedom in how
to express that movement and some
animators have been able to make a name
for themselves by stealing their own
distinctive style into a scene
essentially stealing the show of bits of
really cool segments of animation this
has led to a subset of Japanese
animation called sake girl and without
getting into the nitty-gritty of what
sakuga
actually is as that's a whole other
video entirely suffice to say Sokka is
the animation equivalent to that
15-minute felt mating guitar solo Bobby
brought out at one time there made all
the chicks what and everyone else forget
about the rest of the set you played
that night but if you really want to
as an animator you know the only piece
of animation you need to choose to make
sure the 20 Bobby's you hide aren't
going [ __ ] mental and share some
consistency between their cuts is the
animation director's job to check that
that is the case and make any
Corrections if need be this is a pretty
important role that requires a lot of
experience because for the last [ __ ]
time Bobby there are character sheets
for a reason again you want to express
yourself but you can cover stairway to
heaven with a guitar solo from print
floyd and you can animate this [ __ ]
anime if your characters look like a
bloody horse once the keyframes are done
they are then sent off to the
inbetweeners
the bass guitarist of the anime world
I'm I'm sorry bass guitarist the
in-between is do the grunt work and fill
in the gaps between each frame to make
everything look silky smooth or um or
not apparently they're given
instructions from the key animators for
how many frames they need in-between and
because of the extent of the grunt work
required a lot of times this job is
outsourced to Korea China or Vietnam
wait are you trying to tell me that
anime isn't completely animated in Japan
that's right over this time you thought
you're watching Japanese animu but it
was China made this entire time Japanese
hey man Abu Jahl was animated in Korea
so that's not mean it's not made to
this guy's definitely know why decide
that the inbetweening is normally
outsourced to save costs and saving
costs is something Adam e Studios do
really well and they did it using this
really new innovative business strategy
called
paying your animators [ __ ] like almost
[ __ ] all now you may be thinking that
this sounds like extortion and
borderline slave labor but you know
after all the frames are done they can
be digitized cleaned up and colored in
along with all the backgrounds oh I
forgot to mention throughout the
animation process background artists
have to paint every single background in
every single cut and so everything can
be composited together to create a nice
little bit of anime this is also the
stage where any special effects or CG
can be added to the animation if
necessary and then I said haha we just
make the entire anime in 3d haha Ted
that's actually a brilliant idea no
don't you get it it was a joke I was
making a joke it's no joke how great
that idea was guys guys it was a joke a
[ __ ] joke we're not actually doing
this and once all that is done all
you'll need to do is add all of the
sound effects background music and of
course we can't forget the all-important
alias voice acting you'll need to finish
things off yeah yeah yeah yeah man there
ah all right can we try the take again
just a bit more repeat this time please
and that's it you're pretty much done
for this episode now I just repeat this
for 12 to 24 times throwing a bunch of
overworked animators ungrateful fans
[ __ ] ton of scheduling delays and you
have yourself a full season of anime in
your hands ready to be rushed over and
broadcast where it finally belongs in
all seriousness though I do hope this
video has enlightened some of you to how
hard it can be to get a decent anime
approved let alone the talent to know
how to make it good despite the amount
of mediocrity out there nobody in Japan
is waking up in the morning going hmm
you know what I want to play some
generic piece of [ __ ] today but with the
budgeting timing constraints not to
mention how risky it is getting you an
original anime approved in the first
place and the amount of anime that even
struggle to make a profit is actually
kind of a wonder when a golden egg is
able to be laid it's easy to get
pessimistic without hadi it's actually
make a decent show so if you're watching
something right now that you've really
enjoyed don't forget the massive amount
of work that went into making it maybe
throwing a buck or two that way if
you've really
she ate it and if there's nothing for
you right now chin up there's still
plenty of people in this industry who
want to make something great so I'm sure
you won't have to wait too long you go
try to be educational what a [ __ ]
loser messy hey guys hope you enjoyed
the video thank you very much - Jared
Cattell Tony low gay brown Thomas B and
everyone else impatient for helping sis
for me for this month if you want to see
some way on the stuffing click of the
links around the I'm not sure where
they're gonna be because I'm going to
play up YouTube's and card feature
anyway that's it for me today don't that
money up they stay I've been gig up and
I'll see you all next time